[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
non
il
je
tous
il
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
il
moi
[Musique]
à
salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette grande finale de la coupe des
nations salut fable celica salut à tous
enfin bon on va partir pour la finale
avec une petite déception un petit
regret de ne pas avoir l'équipe
européenne à fabien ouest s'est passé
tout proche et c'est dommage parce que
l'équipe européenne avait son destin
entre les mains et n'ont pas gagné cette
dernière a conquis le reste du monde qui
était quand même la plus petite équipe
du tournoi et donc au final ils peuvent
s'en prendre qu'à eux mêmes
ouais après je t'ai vu un petit peu sur
twitter à juste titre réagir quand les
gens disent et que on a battu les états
unis 2 fois on n'est pas qualifiés au
goal avérage mai mais bon après il faut
bien un goal avérage d'une et ritsu y va
il fallait battre les petites équipes
quoi oui non mais surtout en fait on
peut débattre milan sur le départage
choisi en fait il était connu avant le
tournoi puis c'est tout un fait et des
sports des fossés confrontation directe
des fois c'est qu'aulas virage ça peut
aussi être de pondérer les points que tu
as marqué en fonction de contre qui tu
les as prête jarre bat la chine c'est
plus de valeur que de battre l'un des
attraits du monde
le classement final voilà des choses
comme ça mais l'angle alors l'heure
actuelle au moins on connaissait la
règle et web à savoir est ce c'est pas
pire c'est pas mieux c'est juste temps
choisi un pis c'est comme ça ouais elle
a écouté c'est comme ça et les états
unis
après sur le papier quand une superbe
équipe avec les trois fantastiques et
bas comme en asie ils ont la petite
faiblesse au quatrième et chicken et ils
doivent ça sera qui tu veux aujourd'hui
c'est irina irina aujourd'hui et ben
alors allez blanc aujourd'hui alors je
pense sa mission c'est de tenir est
d'arriver à faire mieux ce sera pour les
enjeux est donc dans cette finale ça
sera en une seule partie donc toujours
une temps dans l'es4 et donc le
vainqueur de ce match sera sacré
champion et s'il ya match nul c'est la
chine qui sera sacré vainqueur
puisqu'ils ont terminé premiers de du
classement général on va dire de la
saison et donc donc les états unis ils
doivent absolument le gagner ce match
s'ils veulent s'ils veulent s'ils
veulent l'emporter alors quoi c'est son
charme et ses voisins at il entendu
parler ce que j'essaie de mettre le chat
quand je voyais le chat sur les caméras
et je me suis battu la faune pour lui m
je crois que sa photo de son avatar sur
certains points comme ça y est ré avec
le charabia font ça les fables le direct
était invité au chant à la guitare et au
chant
non mais dans ce corridor est donc déjà
vainqueurs doivent absolument gagner et
du coup les partis c'est quoi c'est qui
au rating liane avec les blancs comme
une laque à moi on voit mal car on
pourra regretter
il n'y aura qu'à roanne avec les monts
contrôle a je pense qu'ils vont viser
absolument cet échiquier poissy de
gagner c'était vital en fait dans la
stratégie de matches 3d multiplié ses
lions gate et blanc qu'on doit ce
vaisseau alors même si wesley a battu
d'ailleurs c'est il va pas réaliser ce
avec les nerfs des gens normalement et
donc irina doit essayer de tenir cet
automne leur stratégie donc nul aux
échecs et 1 3 4 et aux lignes chez les
femmes bin oui ça peut fonctionner après
il faudra que hikaru soit solide au
premier mais je pense qu'il est en
général wesley so 3 ça m'inquiète pas
trop en revanche seuls irina crouch ou
croche dépend quand c'était le prononcé
aux quatre avaient même avec les blancs
il va falloir faire attention parce que
c'est un peu tout rien et minaj sais pas
si c'est vraiment une joueuse qui s'est
fermé la porte
après si elle peut first nuls dans
l'ouverture à sa place je le ferai mais
en plus ça bien sûr elle me contre wil
fans qui est hyper forte dans un mondial
est juste en fait tous quelqu'un de plus
fort toi donc on va faire un nul c'est
très bien oui mais ce ne sera pas ce ne
sera pas mince affaire
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr écoutez je
pense sa stratégie à des fins un plein
c'est je pense qu'ils veulent fermer la
porte avec lui en guise ou trois
morceaux au 1/10 glee rennes je pense tu
t'es c'est l'ouverture et si t'as pas
grand chose nul et je pense qu'ils sont
tout à fait d'accord de jouer le truc
sur caruana oui et croches
oui les fans sachant que typhon un
partout sur ses deux équipiers
normalement y gagne en taille trop nul
mais ça suffit
dont ils ont enlevé son loi mais je
pense qu'en fait c'est marrant parce que
cette stratégie là elle arrange les deux
français deux équipes sont très contente
de jouer sur l'échiquier 2 et 4 en fait
je pense que limite
enfin patrick matter çà va tombe bien
pour le tirage au sort des couleurs oui
naqab l'encontre dingli run pense pas
que la kapisa ont gagné c'est digne il
ferme la porte
caruana noir justement ce serait encore
plus dur de gagner dans l ouest les eaux
qui pourrait peut-être batterie ion beam
est encore très longue et très solide et
iorek blanche
oui fans s'est quasiment assuré victoire
oui et donc du coup si c'était ça le
match up donc et je pense at elle est
partie des cuites là comme ça
franchement il ya match quoi après il ya
le chat quoi qui peut motiver
détermineront la chaîne brisée il peut
finir à tout le monde à et trésor
l'ouest népalais l'afflux le chat mais
il y avait leur capital aussi aux états
unis il était aussi avec son chaque
pouce à faux avec leur chat je fais pas
tu m le capitaine mais lui aussi c'est
avec wesley il regarder les chalands la
caméra donc c'est une équipe et avec
deux chats après on peut se poser les
bonnes questions comment on perd au
départage société équipe
il avait deux chats mais nous visiter ou
les chats européen à vannes où les
patchs à rabat a mêlé van haver le chien
il a eu le chevronné un petit chat
mignon aussi est très heureux c'est vaut
quoi
c'est pour du coup deux chocs fort qu'un
chien comme les jours et je suis en
train d'un petit peu sur bois sur et
rigoler ce que je vois hikaru qui se
fait le 360° dans sa pièce ils vont vu
qu'apparemment il a le droit d'aller aux
toilettes pour les parties de change de
téléphone ou quoi enfin j'ai envie de
m'en sers pas j'ai le droit mais j'ai
pas réussi à savoir ce qui s'était passé
hier d'ailleurs au final mais dans cette
histoire de téléphone
ouais
et j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas réussi à
lire je passais les gens qui ont trouvé
j'essaie de trouver mais j'ai pas fais
pas vraiment compris le truc donc ça va
débuter dans deux minutes fab est que l
arbitre sera italien fabien pour pour le
côté américain donc ça ne va pas rigoler
filtrer jeu s'évertue à dire non je
pense c'est un peu du sap est le favori
dans le colis ne va pas rigoler c'est un
excellent arbitre a d'ailleurs colline
have a longtemps été course avec le
numéro un je ne sais pas si on est
meilleurs arbitres que lui d'ailleurs
j'en étais vraiment très très bon il
était très respecté en plus c'est
important pour un arbitre bateau
contester des décisions tous trois
secondes
pier luigi coretti je pense que là il
serait pas amusé hikaru très longtemps
alors c'est quelle cadence et tuant 25 +
disque homme comme les autres jours
la cadence reste reste la même pour
cette finale
donc il va durer approximativement une
heure fabien plus ou moins exactement ce
soir et qu'est ce que je lis voilà c'est
peut-être ça aurait pu se faire en match
aller-retour ou quoi mais quand j'ai
décidé comme ça c'est pas si mal ça va
être ça dit régler tout ça je crois
qu'ils avaient quand même le souhait de
donner un vrai avantage à l'équipe qui
avait terminé première
dans la phase de poule a on voit tu as
les caméras qui sont pas encore vraiment
réglé malheureusement moi je vais aller
m car ou qu'il y ait pu désolé les gars
je vais commencer à être les canins mes
joueurs qui viennent qui partit allument
leur cabinet meira qu'il éteigne enfin
fou c'est pas forcément pas forcément
évident c'est quoi les règles en cas de
match nul la chine gagner sinon à celui
qui gagnent gagne voilà pour faire
simple là c'est un peu comme un
armageddon ou les oignons les blancs sa
fille n'ont pas davantage de temps alors
qu'on a un message pour dire que les
parties vont développer dans
approximativement une minute
ok mais j'en aurai starting blocks oui
oui mais non ok pour le coup c'était
quand même assez lisible dans une phase
de poules
il ya une finale ça se finit le dimanche
quelques trucs norme au camp nou
l'histoire ouais avantage à l'équipe je
le répète mais qui a gagné la phase de
groupes ce que je trouve aussi très bien
parce que sinon cette phase de groupe
elle peut devenir pas ça donne un
intérêt à finir premiers quoi swing si
je trouvais tout à fait légitime ça
m'énerve en face à merde j'aime bien
quand la phase de poules a quand même un
intérêt dans la phase finale mais sur
mer en général ils essayent de faire en
sorte enfin que jaro foot la coupe du
monde le premier de poule joue un
deuxième de poule
voilà par le rugby rugby tu reçu joue à
domicile on aime billet je crois que tu
as aussi un avantage au niveau des
terrains et en nfl c'est pour de sûr que
tal avantage du terrain mais je trouve
que c'est c'est bien causer chats qu'ils
aient trouvé ce système de dire tu as
fini pour devant nans groupe
en cas de match nul s'est qualifiée ce
mur est un peu plus tu vérité un peu
plus et c'est logique et c'est plutôt
bien à ce niveau là ça très dur est
plutôt intelligente
il est donc normal normal et donc je
vous prends parler des compos les deux
équipes ont été assainies ont mis leur
équipe type
ils ont sorti dominguez ont gelé trois
fantastiques devant nakamura caruana est
et ouest gso et donc lire une accroche
et chic et 4 et des chinois ils ont
sorti wang hao qui sur le papier bien
sûr les mieux classés qu'eux que du lion
guy who we may bongo avait les tables
ont souffert tout le long de ce tournoi
contre kavala nord un affrontement
direct l'écart du deux fois arrivées
taux zéro est donc voulu éviter le
jamais deux sans trois j'imagine et
remanier un petit peu l'équipe donc
assez logique de composition logique les
entraîneurs qui ont mis tous leurs
atouts sur le terrain mais faut-il
encore que ça suffise fab
alors on va essayer de récupérer la cam
d'hikaru alors attention j'ai connu ce
coach omnium
voilà un très heureux d'aller très très
heureux leur très alerte
ouais il a très très chaud là bas il est
bouillant
ouais la banque à qui il est là bas il
se voit un petit peu le petit et votre
très un petit peu de thé son fameux mur
rouge avec ses petits trophées derrière
et très heureux de tous il est là notre
hikaru par d'autres hikaru hikaru oui
oui mais bon il est très connu dans
cette année tous meilleurs joueurs au
monde il a ouvert sa chaîne de streaming
est il très cool alors c'est parti c'est
bien ça le garric l'ouverture c'est
parti ça à tout blitz et
c'est quoi ça c'est dingli rennes avec
les blancs contre hikaru c'est une
ouverture italienne est bien mais
lorsqu'on va pas pouvoir trop parler
d'ouverture ce que ça allait vite et on
va aller directement là où emmener
maintenant ça va arriver fabien la
position qui est en train de se les
coups se déroule sous nos yeux et il
joue d'une manière j'ai jamais revenu
mais que ce tour à 5 hl oui mais très
heureux nom original originale parce que
en a cinq latour bas défend le pion au
no 5 et entrent en jeu comme ça
d'habitude c'est jamais probante
d'exploser une source si tôt dans la
partie parce qu'elle peut être sujette à
des attaques mais là pour le coup pas
évident d'aller la toucher alors
peut-être le cavalier f1 pour revenir
via les devis e3 quelque part et puis
ces 4 mai mais bon ça va prendre du
temps aux blancs que pierre latour
bougera voilà mais cette idée donc de
pousser le pion à très vite avec les
noirs ça devait passer à la mode
on a vu aussi pas mal de partis ou des
fois les noirs juste amener la dame en
batterie que le fou jusqu'à 7 à se
régler le truc je suis arrivé je sais
pas quoi mais je peux également que je
parle de le nom de caser tout ça ouais
souvent les north s'arrête cette
perception pour libérer 15 à 7 pour la
dame éventuellement et là il a joué à
jouer notre un autre plan mais je pense
à ces nouveaux enfin moi disons que
j'avais jamais vu ça là je pense que
pour ce rachat les deux équipes jouent
vraiment à 100% un fabien il ya quand
même un duel etats unis chine donc c'est
que même sur le plan diplomatique en ce
moment c'est un petit peu un petit peu
chaud entre les deux pays
et ça m'étonnerait que ça joue avec
retenue dans ce match final même si on a
dit que c'était une compétition
d'exhibition une compétition à la
frontière entre l'amicale et le
le l'exhibition et l'officiel mais là
quand même chine etats unis il ya de la
suprématie et chic yens dans l'air c'est
les deux plus grosses équipes du monde
voit c'est un peu de lait leur clope ou
bon ben je sais sont tous européens mais
où tu auras elle pour le match décisif à
un fédérer djoko à nadal djoko ou un
truc comme ça
oui type je sers ils sont tous en europe
au maire c'est juste pour wayne on
m'aimait plus honte a atteint côté pays
aussi dans les derniers jeux olympiques
at c les deux derniers vainqueurs dans
des olympiades la chine et les états
unis laissent un peu commun comme en
urss états unis il ya trente ans qu'on
madame oui ou un brésil italie match de
foot amical il ya une trentaine d'années
quoi du coup non mais du coup c'est moi
cela c'est comme la leur kop cesse
je pense que mon agent et mon calme
préfère gagner un grand chelem molly qui
peuvent gêner la gagnante en convoi
hikaru qui réfléchit sur son siège paix
pouces tranquille et ding ding aussi
tranquille beaucoup de ce sont les deux
tranquille pour monter un sabai dit très
concentré
mais pour le moment c'est la pendule
d'hikaru qui tourne fabien et le joueur
américain c'est comme s'il connaissait
pas je sais pas ce qui va arriver
well done chéquier et à sang il a
beaucoup de dents il ya 123 minutes mais
il faut qu'ils y perdent un ding enfin
c'est sûr que la jolie permis à qu'il
est reparti à tour alors pour avoir
parlé avec un certain vladislav quatre
chefs qui était allé en chine
pour pour un tournoi il avait parlé avec
avec niwa donc le web chinois qui a été
dans le top mondial et qui maintenant
est un entraîneur de renom en chine qui
lui avait dit que tu voies pour
eux-mêmes l'approach eslick donc une âme
une compétition là pour la peine
complètement amical
revêtez déjà pas mal d'importance donc
ils ont une équipe qui s'appelle les
pandas les pandas chinois et que pour
eux c'était une compétition importante
dans le calendrier vraiment comme comme
pour nous quasiment un grande chaise
tour tu vois le raison garder mais tu
vois ce que je veux dire que c'était
quelque chose d'important et donc je
pense je suis même sûr que pour l'équipe
chinoise
cette nations cup a quasiment la valeur
d'une olympiade
surtout cette année en plus il aura pas
d' olympia à cause du corona ils ont
revu tout le calendrier est bien peu
comme les yo qui ont été décalés ballet
sont à l'hôpital n'en ont pas lu aux
échecs et donc cette position c'est pas
trés la remplace mais dans l'esprit un
petit peu maintenant c'est sûr que pour
les chinois la finale c'est vraiment
comme comme une finale de cup comme sûr
jouer une finale des olympiades d'un
gros d'un gros tournoi très clairement
donc si dingli rennes avait une grosse
prépa à sortir dans une italienne
il l'aurait sorti comme dans un four à
des candidats j'ai aucun doute là dessus
monsieur donc attention pour icare ou
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a l'air de
vraiment savoir ce qui fait le joueur
chinois alors se fout en b2 fabien il
est peut-être un petit peu étrange parce
qu' ils tapent dans un pion mais en fait
je pense qu'il veut juste renforcer son
centre bien tout défendre les tours puce
venir au centre penses tu fais un tout
comme dame je sais pas ces deux des
trois dames d3 et tours a dépeint par
exemple je vais vous des coups comme
souvent un pour les noirs avec servent à
rien il sorte qu'on voit bien le plan
voilà je pense à son idée parce que le
four b2 évidemment il aurait un grand
avenir
si jamais les noirs prenez par vous même
en d4 puisqu'on pourra reprendre avec le
pion et un moment avancé
et là évidemment se fout les deux rien à
mon avis qu'on ne va jamais je veux
comme ça ou alors s'il le fait c'est
qu'il enchaînera par le coût des cinq
pour bloquer le plan des quatre blocs et
le fou exactement au bon après bien sûr
ce serait très bien de bloquer mais le
truc c'est que le chou en même temps il
est mobile 1 il épaulait restant bedo de
sa vie et pourrait faire marche arrière
à revenir sur ses pas et en revenir sur
nos petits final donc sur vous pour le
moment il a un peu il un peu
prophylactique
ouais c'est ça il maintient le centre je
pense qu'il va jouer pour passer cet
ours entre mon avis oui alors fou 17
jouait donc ses coups qu'on l'imaginé
pour les noirs de base et donc tu penses
en dames détroit où dame ces deux pour
pour libérer la case est la donnée à la
tour qui viendrait à faire une action
sur cette colonne b qui peut être vous
aussi à s'ouvrir en cas des changes
c'est ça exactement alors après je
dirais plus jeune des trois hommes ces
deux parce que dams et 2 tu peux être
dégradée québec à 5 alors il vient de
chez dams et de fabien mois lorsque à
5-5 ou de suite
ou alors on à la petite jauge on le dit
et prend des prend et regarde une autre
idée fabien un petit peu comment dans la
finale karl scène car yakine si tu te
rappelles dans les départage avait déjà
eu cette idée de la part de carlson de
jouer un jour c4 alors qui peut être
moche parce que ça donne la casse des 4
mai pour venir à
paquet en force le pion aux 5 non c est
du coup qu'il ya cinq marche pas parce
qu'en fait ce pion aux 5 et attaquer et
cylia calais prend b3 les blancs vont
reprendre avec le pion bien remettre
leurs pions solide et d'un gros danger
pour défendre le chose faite comment
très compliqué et ses 5 b 4 qui arrive
aussi pour enfermer le fou donc il ya
plusieurs problèmes en plus non
seulement on peux pas le défendre mais
mais les problèmes sont multiples côté
noir fabien donc on sent que dingli
rennes a joué une position très
venimeuse ici avec les blancs et c'est
vrai que si digne de l'emportent fab
il met son équipe sur de bons rails
ouais là c'est vrai que pour hikaru
c'est vraiment important de son rôle de
bloqueur on l'a pas vraiment dit en
début de match parce qu'on parlait de
stratégie générale mais c'est vrai que
dingli rennes si réussi à faire mal aux
premiers échiquiers adverse le match
serait quasiment gagné pour la chine à
fabien complètement complètement
complète et donc sur ce qu'on regarde en
comprendre le calice et 6 finalement il
est bloqué ici parce que bon choix si on
fait un coup au hasard il fait noir
comme tu veux
car ils agissaient way sur des prendre 5
maintenant va ce serait beaucoup moins
fort parce que on pourrait reprendre du
temps et il craint que les blancs je
romps c4 d'énormes fonds au pire mettre
un fond c5 dont il y aura plus de
pousser le pion aux cinq là il est
défendu
et alors ça ressemble pas à grand chose
à part son meilleur de soi même le fond
le 3 way ou b2c un coup vraiment
prophylactique contre beaucoup de choses
c'est un coût qui empêche cavaliers à 5
c'est un coût qui empêche puis on prend
des 4 et st loup qui empêche quoi ça
permet de mettre la tour en jeu mais sa
part les deux mètres la tour en jeu donc
hikaru qui a mis le cavalier en h7 donc
il pourrait rebondir éventuellement
verges et cinq ce qui enlèverait de la
pression sur le pion de 5,1 puisque on
échangerait lecavalier f6 qu'il ne
défendrait pas le pion 5 et le contre le
cavaliere 3 qui met la pression et ça
mettrait en plus la pression sur le pion
des cadres puisque ça enlèverait aussi
le défenseur enfin un des défenseurs de
décade ont un coût qui met la pression
sur les cases rouges sur l'échiquier
fabien puis d'autres
et au passage si on a une dame à la fin
qui reviendra vers g5
c'est toujours pénible ça se rapproche
du roi plusieurs des clous âge des trucs
comme ça et que je sais ce que tu veux
que je montre je te connais mon fameux
tube pour voir ça voilà tu veux qu'on
voit ça ouais donc juste voir ça veuille
et donc c'est pas un joyau scudo
caillage satie décalé g5 de la part de
di caro et la deuxième idée c'est
peut-être aussi devenez juste la case f6
à la dame pour pour amener à tour du
coin au centre éventuellement alors on
peut faire un tour rapide des
d'échiquier même si on bat largement se
concentrer sur cette partie parce qu'on
va pas avoir le temps de tout voir mais
pour se faire un avis est-ce que fabiano
réussi à mettre la pression sur son
homologue chinois huayi alors on peut
dire déjà au niveau de la jauge fabien
que tu vois le blanc est rentré sur la
cinquième rang j'ai ça veut déjà dire
que les blancs ont pris le dessus et on
voit aux positionnements des pièces à
regarder simplement les blancs qui sont
absolument développer et les noirs un
cavagnan à cinq il ya beaucoup de mal à
revenir au centre le fou ces huit pas
développer on a l'impression que fabiano
là encore a sorti une préparation face à
l'as l'ouverture scandinave de oui oui
tout à fait sûr préférable pour les
blancs et
après une fin mais un truc à fabiano qui
est pas trop mal parti dans cette partie
et voilà qu'à ses chances choix étonnant
la part de oui la scandinave d'amd 8 pas
très bien réputée non bon c'est
relativement solide mais oui c'est parce
qu'ils admirent imputé mais après qu'on
l'ait déjà dit oui il est plus
professionnel il a repris ses études etc
et quand tu joues caruana qui vont lui
pour le coup au niveau national il est
là il est très bien préparée ils bossent
énormément elle est une team avec lui la
jolie je retiens du monde tu as
peut-être pas remis d'un débat théorique
et tu cherches un peu l surprendre
quitte à jouer un truc un petit peu
inférieur mais que tu sais je vois pour
une partie pourquoi alors on fils fabien
vers le troisième est chic et donc que
yang wesley so une partie qu'on s'attend
à être une nulle parce que wesley so
c'est un des joueurs les plus solides du
circuit yundi qui est aussi très solide
et finalement les chinois ont pas
vraiment intérêt à prendre des risques
là dessus parce qu'on sait que que
wesley so c'est un excellent contreur
c'est peut-être le meilleur contreur du
circuit faut pas une miette
donc là c'est une partie voilà qui
semble qui semble être un peu sans
histoire pour le moment et dernier chic
y est primordial côté américain et c'est
une variante des changes de la française
excellent choix d'ouverture côtes
américains fabien oui complètement pour
donner de jouer une position symétrique
pendant lequel il peut un témoin de
bricoles en général même si bien sûr y
aura rien fait mais en tout cas on voit
que les blancs ils sont là pour vraiment
solidifier les ont mis leurs chaînes
d'options me sens très bon site ou bien
développé et changer les torts sur la
colonne ouverte dès qu'il y en aura une
en face et liquider le plus possible le
matériel donc clairement à une accroche
ou pour regarder du score allez on va
retourner sur le premier échiquier qui
d'après ce qu'on vient de voir pourrait
être déterminant fabien puisque fabiano
caruana au deuxième est en train de
remplir sa mission
donc les américains qui pour avoir une
mission remplie deuxième mission qui
semble pouvoir être rempli par wesley so
et il en restera plus que deux ne sera
plus que de que deux cases à cocher la
case di caro avec la nulle et peut-être
la plus difficile celle d'hier in
accroche au dernier chic y est mais
irina qui fait
début de partie excellent pour le moment
très bon choix très bon choix
pas de risque et oui elle est
complètement capable de tenir ce genre
position alors voisine glee rennes
maintenant qu'ils commencent enfin à
réfléchir
il est bien concentré comme il faut
c'est en train de jouer et hikaru qui va
devoir se concentrer après le courage de
mais j'imagine que le joueur chinois est
encore plus ou moins dans sa préparation
fabien il ya très peu réfléchi alors il
je sais pas s'il a déjà vu cette
position passe comme si le tour à cinq
extraits j'ai jamais vu mais en tout cas
il alors savoir ce qui fait presque est
tour f1 et f4 peut être une idée ici
pour complètement changé le fusil
d'épaulé et essayer de tu vois wave 4
passes a pas de système et d'autres sur
un ton tout versé un ou des choses comme
ça weight touré font tousser un f4 oui
j'ai oublié dire le fou certes mais ma
foi peut-être alors qu'il ya cinq jouer
arrive maintenant c'est bien maintenant
c'est possible
alors quand tu vas jouer ton pour ses
cartes voit plus du tout attaquer le
pion de 5 alors pour le coup par contre
rien cloches vont par contre deux pions
donc peut-être prendre en b3
intermédiaire apprend les dom prendre
soin d'un proche
j'aime assez les noirs en fait avec la
paire de flou bon avec les blanches
france et jouer que ces quatre toute
façon pour donner vie à sauver deux et
ensuite joué avec le cavaly g36 leur
harnais verlhac 5
et puis une tour sur un troisième rangée
en d3 quand j'ai 3
c'est ce genre de plan qui veut mettre
en place avec les blancs parce que juste
pour montrer l'arrivée du cahier f5 donc
la kiné qui n'est pas possible fabien
mais on jouerait avec un tandem
cavaliers fou sur 15 noir exactement ça
fait très dangereux la tour qui peut
venir en soutien plus madame un i peut
ramener du lourd en raison peut ramener
une toutes les pièces que je mets en
rouge sur l'échiquier peuvent tout
attaquer le point le point g 7 ans on
pourrait mettre quatre attaques sur sur
ce pion devant le roi c'est vrai que si
on y arrive avec les blancs se serait
matt quasiment automatique mais la route
est longue
la route est longue et en plus si on le
voit nous il ya des chanteurs ou se
méfie de tout ça elle est bon non mais a
disons les mares ski race qui pourra
toujours faire cesser de construire un
petit mur en faisant f6 le cas échéant
admettant qu'elle valait proche ou moyen
bouquet profond avant s'arrêter mieux un
truc comme ça ça peut être une idée pour
bien blindé alors on n'était pas obligé
de le faire trop tôt mais à un moment
dès qu'on sent que ça choque un peu trop
s'il calais sera reine trop pressée de
le prendre et autres pièces blanches
oui qui peut intervenir sur f5 ou sûrs
achetant un cas assez facilement
il est noir après bon là tous ravis de
film n'est pas mal placé parce que
peut-être qu'avant pour la rentrée de
l'onda colonnes car pour l'instant il ya
rien à venir y faire mais ça peut être
une idée à n'importe quel moment et
aussi une autre idée des noirs c'est
finalement s'il n'ya pas trop avec le
roi peut-être essayer d'ouvrir la
position 1 - c6 des simples ou f5 même
pour justement ouvrir parce que les fous
ils ont besoin que le jeu sauveur comme
ceux des pièces longue portée s'il ya
trop d'options devant leur champ de
vision
ils sont astreints par contre le jour où
tout s'ouvre là je dis variable donc
pour jouer contre le cavalier en tout
cas c'est ce que fait icaew et inglee
rennes qui réfléchit qui est peut-être
déjà en danger face à hikaru nakamura
qui est vraiment impérial en cette
période de confinement fabien j'ai
l'impression que ça lui réussit plutôt
bien
il a quand même un niveau de jeu sur
internet en rapide qui est
impressionnant seul magnus carlsen
réussi à le battre
voilà par magnus sinon c'est cavalier
seul le côté hikaru qui donne
l'impression vraiment de marcher sur
l'eau en fête pendant très longtemps il
était considéré comme étant le meilleur
jeu online
finalement on s'est rendu compte que
comme cap seine c'est juste le meilleur
partout mais caron et qu'elle n'est pas
loin derrière ya une marge
à quelque part pour faire un petit tour
des stades parce que la position
de caruana pour être vraiment
primordiale face à huy et caruana a déjà
un pion plus fabien ouais alors sait
jamais si c'est un bloc dans ces
circonstances mais c'est quand même
important a signée s'est en plus
évidemment ce que on a du mal à les
avancées et ils sont attaquables pour
l'instant une tendance et vite
il ya les deux shows braqué un peu sur
cette aile dame ya le cav a laissé six
qui peut bondir jérôme r pk des trucs
comme ça et là oui pour le moment mais
oui
excuse moi j'étais enfin mais je veux
dire c'est pas si simple d'avancé ce dès
qu'on va toucher un avion ça va faire
des trop pleins pleins coup comme
détroit comprendre c'est très mauvais
parce que ça va aligner le cavalier la
tour par bouby de hofu g7 et est donc
c'est pas gagné d'avancé mais les
manguiers sur carmona qui calcule hyper
bien je pense
il est dans son élément pour être précis
et trouver à trouver le tour les bons
coups pour solidifier tout en avançant
après si on réussit à mettre le pion c4
et l'autre en b3 pour faire une chaîne
de prière comme celle ci ça va bien se
passer
voilà ce sera vraiment un cran de plus
ils seront pas attaquable et là pour le
coup ça prendra fin j'ai en fait en gros
s'il cherche à faire on va voir s'il y
arrive mais connaissant fabiano caruana
numéro deux mondial
il devrait y arriver donc ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour les américains
aient finalement maintenant ce sont les
chinois qui sont à la recherche de
points fabien on peut dire que le match
prend une physionomie complètement
différente de dupré match puisque après
match c'était aux américains de faire
l'effort pour gagner une partie quelque
part et maintenant les américains ils
peuvent vraiment dira écoutez maintenant
c'est nous qui avons notre point de plus
avec fabien neo 2 en espérant qu'ils
gagnent 1 mais c'est c'est ce qu'ils
peuvent dire entre guillemets ou aux
chinois et vire bam annoncé sur les
trois autres échiquiers c'est vraiment à
vous de faire quelque chose on s'en
fiche on blinde
on va chercher les nuls et puis on aime
et on mise tout sur fabiano best of
advanced le plan de match
logique annoncé en fait ce qu'on dise
avant le match non hélas ascani ça mais
ça m'est vraiment une vraie pression
maintenant abomination mais je pense que
les joueurs font pas trop qui regarde ce
qui se passe à côté qui se focalise
de yu yongding ils essayent de jeu pour
le gain sans s'envoyer en l'air
cui fans elle joue pour gagner jusqu'au
dernier moment et ses sympathies
normalement je dois faire alors côté
willie fans et ce qu'est ce que la
joueuse chinoise répond aux joueurs
américains
pour le moment j'ai envie de te dire la
position encore très symétriques mai
mais bon on est accueilleront ce coup
l'ouverture vient de finir et c'est
maintenant que willy fans va vraiment
produire son effort fabien pour réussir
à prendre le dessus sur nrj n'accroche
et remettre toute la pression sur
l'équipe américaine
mais en fait le truc c'est que ce genre
de deux parties une française des
changes c'est un très long combat pour
essayer de gagner canard parce qu'en
fait les lancerons jamais mieux mais
c'est d'être les blancs à force de ne
pas vouloir bouger une oreille tu peux
faire des petites concessions petit à
petit et c'est en ça que c'est pas
évident en jeu pour faire mieux mais si
les blancs arriva justement si un moment
faut jouer collectif ne pas avec le
frein à main
il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils tiennent
pas la petite petite inquiétude d'un
côté chinois je vois qu'ils ont du mal
avec leur connexion aujourd'hui il se
déconnecte un petit peu est ce que ça
peut avoir un être un facteur important
à un moment donné ça m'étonnerait mai
mais attention tout de même alors que
côté côté du coup échiquier numéro 1
fabien gilles caron qui semble vraiment
commencé à mettre la pression maintenant
comme tu le disais la position en train
de s'ouvrir les blancs n'ont pas
vraiment d'attac les tours sont en train
de rentrer sur la colonne a des
faiblesses un peu sur cases noires le
fou qui pourrait atterrir en c6 et sans
prendre option de 4 on a l'impression
qu'une nouvelle fois le joueur américain
est impérial dans cette partie ouais est
ce que c'est possible de voir
l'enchaînement des trois quatre derniers
coups sûrs s'étaient quittées après les
rouages de la voilà ici et voir comment
ils sont arrivés là parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de coureurs en fait un peu de
temps donc il faut c'est un qui ont eu 5
ouais il a pris ce chemin comme prévu
est ok et d'après qu'une tour est parti
de là bas d'accord alors on peut
comprendre un but qu'il a le foot cases
noires il a décidé de mettre ses pions
sur cases blanches essayé par la suite
de jouer ses cartes on joue un coût nul
pour les noirs de jouer ces cas d'avoir
les pions qui contrôle les cases
blanches comme je suis en train de le
montrer avec les flèches et d'avoir le
fou qui contrôle les cases noires donc
on voit avec toutes les cases que j'ai
colorier fabien qu'il ya vraiment une
double double emploi puis on fout ouais
c'est parfait comme ça
seulement symbiose et c'est très
efficace mais le truc c'est que la tour
peut arriver en a deux et que tu as
symbiose bras quand ça va pas être
facile de jeu le coup donc ces quatre
pour info parce que ce fou serait
attaqué deux fois
voilà et la dame donc faudra attendre un
petit peu avant de réviser ce qui est au
delà de ça le fousseret subi un pur un
clouage donc là parce qu'il est
mobilisée exactement là où père logique
un tour à deux pour les quarts où je
sais pas s'il a joué mais
on sait pour sa septième rangée c'est
très bien placé c'est fort en en parlait
il ya très longtemps a détruit une tour
peut-être un jour pour arriver je crois
que le jour est arrivé et c'est leur
logique post its et 4 carrières pénibles
tu place ta tourbier comme il faut et
puis si tu mets ta tour en 1 2 pas
d'amoureux 5 qui sera pas délogea parce
que le fou et nenê n'est pas n'est pas
actif et que réussi à faire des petites
carabistouilles peut-être un jour avec
des fouets f2 qui rentrent ou du c6 des
5 pouces et 7 % prendre la roi ça on
voit vraiment un scénario où ça pourrait
très vite tourné à l'avantagé des noirs
mais peut-être que les plans avec tour
d'eure réussissent à blinder et n'a pas
le temps de faire damner 5 parce que tu
te fais chasse est ce le fousseret
protéger c'est peut-être ça l'idée
défensive de dingli rennes face à cette
attaque il semblerait même très logique
côté noir fabien oui mais voilà rebonds
ont peut-être n'en vois pas mettre la
dame lorsqu'ils sont réalisés si tôt
mais quoi qu'il en soit c'est pas malin
pour nous on va voir fabien écoute les
noirs qui semble avoir une position
intéressante après attention on n'en a
pas reparlé mais si les blancs a
contrario réussissent à faire ces quatre
et kamal et h5 là ça pourrait être un
gros problème et la dame en c3 sur la 4g
c'est donc il va vraiment y avoir un
combat dans les prochains coups pour
savoir qui va réussir à faire mal sur 15
noir exact exact c'est très concret et
falloir bien calculé pas se tromper
parce que d'ailleurs un coup comme tour
ado qui comble et l'hyper logique viens
de me rendre compte que peut être il ya
eu 5 pour les mains et on n'a pas très
envie entre deux france au bout parce
que puis en trombe à la fois la reprise
donc aurait bougé la dame alors je sais
pas à quel point c'est grave ou pas mais
déjà ça peut être préoccupante et âme
inscriptions marib sur mon rock qu'est
ce qui se passe mais le pion eu six pour
être dangereux alors après est ce que le
fou c6 qui contre attaque g2 est assez
fort pour compenser le pion au 6 qui est
qu'à 2 càs de dames et qui met la
pression sur le roi noir ça après c'est
aux joueurs de juger c'est extrêmement
complexe évidemment c'est tout c'est
tout le fond du jeu d'échecs et après
c'est aussi grâce à leur puissance de
calcul bien plus forte que la nôtre qui
réussissent à juger des positions et
d'ailleurs ils jouent tour à 2 d'hikaru
donc il a jugé que 5 n'était pas un coup
suffisamment fort pour le mettre en
danger alors là au 5e tour 2 semble les
deux coups en fabien voix semblable on
trouvera de plus solide
ouais garde les options non avec tours
de entre garde cinq possibles on regarde
le sait car on fait pas mal de choses si
on on pourra doubler les tours suivants
la colonne pourra occuper ça m'a l'air
d'être le coup du coup qui tient pas
trop mal de la pression
alors après peut-être tourin aussi
possible pour aller c'est de liquider
cette tour finalement way to reprend
tout reprends toi que je prends siph et
de nos 5
cette fameuse dame qui arrivant au sein
qui va bien et qui va commencer à avoir
dit à m quatre fois f2 ou d'un mètre
quatre dames trois dames gère d'ailleurs
pour se faufiler ou du talent c'est cinq
dames bien même que j'avais pas vu de
base pour se faufiler sur cases noires
ça semble faire mal ding et rennes qui a
joué il a joué tour de fabien lemoine le
plus plus solide un mais à mon avis il
n'a pas il permet d'échanger les tours
ding parce que même si les tours du
carrosse ou pas mal cette colonne 1
pour l'instant ils les cloisons avec son
dams et de chou b2 est alors pas trop où
il contrôle les cases au tour à 3 et 1
par exemple que lui avec ses tours il
fait le taff quoi il est là au centre
et si le centre sous rooney veut il veut
il vote prépondérant ici quoi et à mon
avis si on enlève les tours de cette
position du coup bas qu'on l'a dit la
dame peut s'implanter au mieux les noirs
on va voir beaucoup moins de mal comme
dessein l'instant pas trop possible avec
la tour en d1 le 4 mai c'est un fc tours
bombe à la suite il va suffire notre
influence et 6 par exemple et ça va
aller très vite et puis finalement c'est
tour elle bloque aussi l'action de la
dame s'il faut arrivants ces six pour
jouer de concert avec la dame pour
menacer m'attend j'ai de la tour et là
quelque part ces deux tourelles font un
peu tout elle contrôle le centre et
elles défendent le roi et elles peuvent
aussi monter pour attaquer le roi
adverse alors que c'est vrai que comme
tu disais l'étourdi car où elles sont
toutes les deux sur la colonne a alors
bravo palmarès je touve foulée 2 mais à
part quelques foulées 2 elles font pas
grand chose de plus mais du coup et cas
où il a mis en place
cette ode défensives dont parle le petit
mur contre le four b2 mais maintenant
cavalier h5 karelia 4 et je reviens vers
des 5es verger 6 voilà il ya des idées
comme ça possible à mon avis il va
vouloir juste bientôt des formats
qu'elle replace et peut-être son fou 17
ans les recettes via les huit pour
bétonner un peu tout ce qui peut
éventuellement faire un pion ans et 6 1
français 5 4 comme ça alors je propose
qu'on fasse un petit tour pour voir
comment ça évolue tout d'abord fabiano
caruana donc il ya toujours son pion de
plus et ça semble écoute petit à petit
rentrée vers la victoire peut-être un
coup ici comme fou à 6 pour venir gêner
la tour noire
l'activité commence être en faveur du
joueur américain
j'ai peu de doute un sur une victoire
américaine dans cette partie ouais même
pareil allez on peut aller voir
notre ami yu yang yi contre wesley so du
hongi qui met une petite pression quand
même hein il va avoir la colonne des
avec les blancs seul coup la fin une des
deux seules colonne verte sur
l'échiquier mais les noirs ont pas
encore terminé le développement et le
pouvoir chinois est pas mal hein oui
bien sûr mais c'est pas gratuit il a
donné un pion alors après par contre
c'est clair que je vais sans doute
qu'elle évite sont à toi 8 c'est pénible
j'ai vu des parties du parc du fort
logiciel alpha 0 qui avait battu une
autopsie changement des partis comme ça
c'est très dur quand les noirs mais dans
le courant dation votre question ce
magic qui venait bien contré et ça peut
lui convenir en fait de devoir défendre
entre les seuls coûts repoussé repoussée
et puis à la fin mai japon plus on verra
ce que ça donne fabien et dernier chic y
est il ya une accroche qui pour le
moment tient la position mais ça va être
une position au long cours et où guy
fans qui va pouvoir mettre la pression
pendant pendant des heures et des heures
et peut-être à en fin de partie si le
sort du match se jouait sur cet
échiquier
ça pourrait être difficile
psychologiquement à tenir pour irina
croche donc quand même petit avantage
pour les chinois ici même si rinne a
réalisé une grosse partie pour le moment
pour l'instant rien à dire elle tient
très bien la position mais voilà si elle
continue à bien jouer comme ça elle
perdra pas là je suis en tout cas où il
faille n'a lui a tout tenté pour essayer
de la faire déraper un moment où aller
on retourne sur sur hikaru nakamura qui
a ramené sa tour en six ans il en avait
marre y avait une menace en fait quand
on s'est quittés il ya eu il ya eu le
fameux plan aux cavaliers h5 fouet huit
cavaliers hk dont on parlait sait si ces
dames b1 avec une masse très discrète
fabien sur un coup et comme fou à vii
il voulait jouer fou prend m6 menace la
dame et la tour qui aurait été en prise
enfin deux variantes donc ça aurait
gagné une qualité et un pion pour les
noirs donc la tour est reparti en a six
et on voit maintenant comme tu disais
que c'est finalement les tournois qui
sont peut-être moins bien placé que les
tours blanches et d'ailleurs
les tours blanches qui commence à
s'approcher à une tour qui arrive en d3
il peut y avoir doublage de tours avec
tours d2 et la tour défendre à la case
de 3 il peut y avoir tout rejet 3 pour
venir s'en prendre aux pions g7 et
augmenté la pression
j'ai l'impression que ce cet
enchaînement de coups de diglee rennes a
fait a fait mal aux joueurs américains
ouais c'est vrai et il faudra pas
oublier peut-être un jour alors je sais
pas quand tu sais toujours pas ce qu'il
va faire mais j'ai 4 h 4g 5 pour venir
vraiment complètement a donc à semur
qu'ils ont mis en place pour faire le
fou b2 donc et les tours qui viendrait
sur la colonne g et que tout le monde
dise laura après le problème de faire ça
c'est que ça a subi aussi son propre
droit en enfer et prendre le chou les
six pourra revenir vers ses sets et va
la faire ce genre de choses alors faudra
bien le times et donc pas le faire en
claquant des doigts n'importe comment
mais ça et que ça peut devenir une idée
je vois que l'ordinateur propose un coup
très intéressant et si fabien dame f1
pour venir protéger un petit peu ce
cavalier et jouer après g4 et envoyé
peut-être dans un deuxième temps donc
peut-être d'un met fin aux préparatifs
voilà les foires préparé pour ce sens
avec les blancs ce qui est bien je pense
ici je dois dire que je pense vraiment
qu'ils ont davantage les normes peuvent
rien faire car oui c'est marrant parce
qu'on avait l'impression qu'ils caro
avait vite et bien sorti l'ouverture est
finalement là ding bas peut-être ce coût
d'un jeu certes un peu passif mon père à
sarcelles et vraiment mieux à faire ou
pas on aurait aimé pouvoir placer cette
dame au centre ou faire un truc plus
plus dynamique et il a plutôt joué pour
solidifier et donc du coup ding a pu se
mettre en place
donc ce couvert 5 qui lit chez pas ça va
peut-être une partie de la sq est
capable en clair je sais plus dans une
espagnole des changes pour alice de la
case aussi ce qu'on demande c'est quoi
l'idée taref armature otage son cavalier
tueur place la dame qui fait plus grand
chose en d1 et quand tu feras gk du coup
va t'on cavaliers protéger put adaptées
peut-être plus facilement venir en g2
vas-tu te replaces du côté des chéquiers
ou où tu es actif tout simplement déçu
maintenant puis qui seul peut rebondir
en f3
verger 4 j'ai trop faim elle fera plus
de choses en bien là fait que la terre a
chassé la torah de l a défendu son fou
mais en fait une fois que votre pièce a
rempli son rôle un endroit elle a
peut-être plus grand chose à y faire
donc autant c'est toujours se dire tiens
est-ce que j'ai moyens de mieux placer
une pièce est toujours leur en demander
plus allez c'est parti dans la tactique
justement fabien avec tours j'ai trois
pouces et 7 tempo et cavaliers g6 et là
on voit que le fou maintenant est quand
même assez bien placé a parlé de ces
pièces qui se déplaçait sur b6 au début
il y avait leur engin il était bien
placé le roi par an age 2 est le fou
symétriquement via c7 pour pour se
remettre en face de lui et là la
position en train de prendre une
tournure très complexe faller ouais et
alors là on pourra toujours faire très
très attention aux coûts des 5 1 pour le
oui/non la police il passait à niang au
smic mais en général il va bouger de
façon stable et des 5 c'est un coup à
toujours faire attention parce que déjà
concrètement ça peut gagner une qualité
de le pousser cet oncle à tours angers 3
mai deuxièmement c'est un coucou rêve de
faire hacker noir simplement pour
exposer le centre ouvre la position et
enlever ce gris tout la clé blanc ont
sous la pression pour commencer et on en
parlait déjà un peu avant quand on
possède les foules ça s'ouvre en fait ça
fait tellement choses bien tous deux
pour les noirs que c'est clairement un
coup pouvait d'un visa ouais alors à
voir ce que va jouer à hikaru là-dessus
d'amd 820 coup logique un faux projet
ici j'y crois pas trop mon truc avec un
look en train de danser là sur la caméra
on voit ça et des papiers regard et
c'est peut-être qui peut faire [ __ ]
angers 6 poursuivre par des cinq le coup
d'après oui mais alors n'y avait pas
cinq ici ouais mais le pion de iphone
pour le pour l'instant bonjour c'est
parce qu'on compte en faire mais le truc
c'est que dès que tu prends je réussis
détour eu six mois non ça complique les
choses mais ça peut être une option
qu'ils pour ça qu'ils dansent peut-être
ya réfléchi à ça j'aurais dit je bouge
l'adamois naturellement sans trop donner
mon fou comme ça de caisse blanche mais
peut-être c'est ça qui la tire qui fait
qu'ils passent du temps sur ce coup en
tout cas quand il commence à danser
gérant c'est mauvais signe pour
l'adversaire là c'est ça y regarder y
danse à fond là est très heureux de tout
rires il se fait des pizzas il va
commencer les grimaces est le festival
ça et c'est le festival hikaru qui est
parti petit grimace allez on regarde un
peu en bas peut-être un petit coup vers
le plafond derrière non oui tension fab
est ce que la danse devant repartir tout
autre qui danse mais caché le gourou à
la norme et là ça va repartir on danse
là c'est pas possible avec s'arrêter
trop longtemps là mais peut-être que
l'oeil d'une mesure où ce regard là un
vieux nassau a essayé très énervé très
énervé la mauvaise surprise mais a fait
appel à projets 6ème mais il a fait la
petite grimace avant de prendre quand
même dingue il doit faire sûrement je
sais pas si sûr son ensemble il ya des
chances qu'ils suivent corps des cinq
voiliers la petite grimace auront de
problèmes des 500 avait senti le mais
ils dansent plus là il ya un truc qui
n'a pas pu y peut-être que les prochains
coups votes très importants arrivent ils
se concentreront énorme et c'est je
pense qu'il y avait qui étaient très
proches du gain quoi après hassaïm lagos
et elle est repartie a laissé bien non
mais j'adore enfin ses rayons regard
d'un petit coup de flash un petit
courant regarde les flics et ça y est la
c mais les parties femme là il est parti
mais produit son attaque vraiment marre
à regarder quand même quand il fait ça
il fait tellement marrer cc festival qui
va tout faire toutes ces positions là
c'est fini c'est à dire l on fasse un
style complètement différent au niveau
de la concentration voit plus plus
classique fabien eux développer
normalement
bref très concentré et aikau dire voit
le temps mais ils concentrent aussi car
on sait juste qu'il extériorise plus ses
sentiments et juste de manière ferme et
on ne peut pas dire qu'ils pensent à
autre chose que la partie mais peut-être
côté aussi pour se motiver et que tu te
rendes dans un truc comme ça
ouais ou alors qui c'est passé en tête
une vitesse de calcul quantique calcul
loin des variantes peut-être c'est un
genre de rythme de coude en jeu j'ai
pensé ça a parfois dit chantal
ventilatoire cement route
hikaru each of fate est comme un
métronome en fait c'est genre tu
accélères le calcul tic tac tic tac et
puis après tu es laïka route et vous
alors naturel était celui-là là il est
déçu
ouais y'a rien un truc qu'il ya un truc
dans une variante qui se passent pas
comme il voulait toujours à 2 en tout
cas ça le hockey ce qu'ils comptent
faire cet arc en fou pour faire [ __ ]
on le 5
c'est pour ça qu'il est si heureux et je
pense qu au brushing va donner aussi la
qualité ouais il place son fou très bien
placé et il doit penser que ça vaut la
qualité est ce qu'il a un pion pour la
qualité
il a un pion passé qui peut un petit peu
avancé à leur one faible parce que les
pions sont sur blanc et le fouet sur
noir donc les cases noires qui sont
complètement affaibli je te coupe
famille hermès est en même temps mais le
fauteuil tout effort la tour qui peut
rentrer un la tour j'ai sicilia du mal à
revenir en jeu parce qu'elle devoir
passer par g4 et angers 4 toute la
quatrième rangée
elle est obstruée jésus avec en plus
dans les finales nationales en tant que
rage 5j pas moins de 100 miles aurait
plus de gaz
allez donc je comprends je comprends il
doit voir qui il doit avoir un coût qui
sauve les blancs qui fait que c'est pas
complètement gagnant qu'il a arrêté de
danser mais on comprend pourquoi au
début il il dansait partout pas bon
alors attends refaire un tour vers les
autres échiquiers mais ça se passe mal
pour la chine mais alors c'est quoi ça
c'est toujours carmona l'assomption de
plus équipe qui travaille encore
convertir yun junghee qui maintenant est
peut-être passé d'un rôle de bloqueur un
rôle de buteur côté chinois
fabien peut-être les chinois peuvent
plus se permettre d'avoir un guillon guy
avec les blancs qui fasse diouf mais
quand tu as des raisons qui l'a jamais a
eu lui sur la zone où on lui attribuait
mais finalement comme il a sacrifié ses
pions et ils jouent ils jouent vraiment
pour rapporter quelque chose après on se
rappelle que dans les tournois où il ya
eu bien eu d armageddon c'était donc
c'était des parties décisives à la fin
des parties qui jouent et surtout ils
étaient très efficaces en avant c'est
parti must win avec victoire obligatoire
il était vraiment très efficace et
peut-être que ces matches au contraire
le désigne comme un nominé il était
dangereux dans les grands prix fidh
il y en a eu quatre l'an dernier donc
chaque jour en jour et 3/10 passer des
tours l'avait éliminée par exemple est
bonne à rognan dans un des grands prix
c'est un bon joueur très dangereux donc
attention les amis et les chinois qui
peuvent essayer de répondre et là par
contre ça se passe quand même assez bien
pour irina crachin après ça vient
d'arriver à vraiment sécher la position
improbable qu'elle perde
à noter dans les finales de dames il
peut y avoir beaucoup de jeu juste
montrer un truc car je vais rejoindre au
noir tu as même là tu pourrais donner le
pion b2 à l'échec perpétuelle exactement
sur cette diagonale et si les noirs par
l'échec par g6 du coup on l'aurait ici
on peut quand même faire du loup est
plus ambitieux la porte vu qu'il ya que
ça qui me fasse dans l'exemple voilà mes
mais pour instruire une accroche qui
remplisse son rôle à merveille
oui ben là ça me paraît vraiment
difficile même juste de près c'est parce
qu'il ya trop d'échecs perpétuelle d'une
grave grave et rare début en mai
pour l'instant il ya pas vraiment faire
un moyen de pièces sur l'échiquier moins
une chance de faire d'erreur et irina
alors comme on l'a dit elle est moins
forte sans adversaire mais je crois bien
alors après peut-être le choix de
l'ouverture de deux oui fans de jouer
une française les échanges mais en fait
avant lui s'y attendait pas parce que
c'étaient des quatre le premier two way
les battre si cela devait vouloir jouer
je sais pas que des petits qui négligent
les quatre échecs ou des sortes de
hollandaise jeu c'est pas un truc
justement compliqué et là le 4 bons qui
a tendance est toujours possible
quand tu fais au 6 mai mais en tant que
joueur de 1 des 4 en général tu as il
reste plusieurs schémas plutôt de
switcher sur le jeu 2,4 c'est très bien
fait de la partie rina et du coup il le
problème c'est que ces noms des changes
la française alors c'est pas un vrai
ment soit pour les noirs parce que
normalement on peut pas appeler ça un
problème d'égalité avec et leurs échecs
on est plutôt sens est sous pression et
donc égalisé c'est un accomplissement
content de l'espoir mais le truc c'est
quand on est supposé être le genre le
plus fort on veut bien égalisé n'est pas
que ce soit complètement plat d'ailleurs
passer par la case égalisation avant de
gagner et donc souvent en fait quand on
est un peu en must win the depression
plus compliqué quitte à être qu'ils
soient un petit peu inférieur aux il ya
comme charles le plus fort ce sera plus
compliqué je vais faire la différence
ensuite donc dingli rennes qui est dans
le dur
fabien parce qu'il peut pas vraiment
éviter la grande qu'on l'a regardé un
l'option est cloué la menace est tombée
de tomber de fouquereuil cinq échecs qui
récupère et la tourner en croit h1 et
plus ou moins forcé et il pourra pas il
faudra pas éviter cette suite pour il ne
pourra pas éviter cette finale cette
position fabien et il va y mettre en
difficulté du mien alors après les noirs
juste ok bon elle va reprendre
rassemblement après peut aussi faire
tout ici il a repris bon ça tombe mal au
dos histoire prend je vais pas comme
l'élite puisque le fou et que donc il
peut aller nulle part il attend derrière
donc tout reprend fou s'il veut vraiment
le faire il va le faire et d'ailleurs
roy h1 faut prendre cinq séquences 7h35
qu'il assume ce qu'on va te couperont
pas trop possible mais c'est ça va pour
prendre les vestiges suivante
ok tu fait très mal dans certains cas là
sans le savoir parce que ça aurait pu
champions pour les noirs mais en fait
perdre la partie nord mais il va c'est
la qualité qui es tu sûr alors est ce
que il adapte en rentrant tour 3 alors
pour prendre les deux que bon c'est deux
ans s'appelle avait dedans avant de le
faire mais ce qui te faire autre chose
attends c'est quoi surprendre notamment
prend fondation marc ronson
il veut bouger le mois 1,6 et rendre la
qualité tout de suite car je croise dans
le christ ce qui veut rentrer dans cette
finale les deux pions base et sans trop
de forme de pions pas le celi en finale
du monde c'est maintenant la main très
difficile à arrêter
le roi des noirs les plus actifs
beaucoup de choses qui font que les
noirs sont bien normalement d'avis
surtout tombé dedans me tromper de
frouzins qu'il me soit bouger droit soit
faire g3 mais quelle a été la intérêts
ne pas commencer par bouger le roi en
fait pour avoir peut-être qu'il n'aimait
pas être un échec là un moment mais je
sais pas j'ai un oncle aurait faible
juste tu sais le coup le courage 5 ou
voulais faire il est doublement bon
parce qu'il enferme la tour tu l'as h 4
enfin c'est un enjeu car ou caro il
mieux voilà un tweet ce sacrifice après
peut-être mais vous dans le prochain
qu'on peut pas faire maintenant
chatel 6 maintenant c'est sa mère d'être
compromis pour digne si ça tient sur le
fil de rasoir
après dix mille est connu pour être
capable de faire une grosse défense et
hikaru qui grimacent encore ali riahi
est pas content il cessa bon de feuilles
de bluffer dans sept autres n'arrivent
pas non regarde et dégoûté améliorer la
lecture et voyez beaucoup mieux mais on
a l'impression qu'il est complètement
fou tu n'en regarde mais c'est un
spectacle mais un autre joueur qui était
très expressive c'était kasparov un
salon d'époque pour vous pouvez me le
fais un peu son histoire du maroc à
dakar où il est marrant alors à temps
pour faire un tour des stades
caruana
alors c'est quoi ça tend sa une il va
reprendre cette pièce mais haute corse
et de subtiles prend il ya tour c'est
cette attaque le cavalier de préférence
était cloué les tours 5
et sur ces 5 tu vas perdre une pièce
donc il faudra prendre leur tour et les
noirs qui reprennent immédiatement ces
deux et uc quoi caruana te plaignais
il va peut-être pas gagné parce que là
les noirs se sont activés quand même un
la tour en c2 qui va jouer de concert
avec le fou g7
admettons tu fais ton huit cavaliers 3,8
et comment tu défends ce pion à je crois
qu'il va le perdre mais bon peut-être
faire autre chose constante prendre un
peu de temps en noir mais ouais mais
c'est un seul comme ça c'est pas gagné
d'avancé truc quelques pions plus
commenté sous pression
en tout cas grosse défense de wii ainsi
réussi à tirer la nulle ce grain on vous
rappelle il joue contre le numéro deux
mondial
il est amateur entre guillemets faina
plus professionnelle en tout cas donc il
n'a plus d'ouverture il part avec un
sacré handicap et tirer une nulle dans
une position pareille c'est équivalent
une victoire bah ça peut faire gagner
son équipe
ça peut rattraper un peu la difficulté
dingli rennes alors échiquier numéro 3
bon alors la femme c'est n'importe quoi
et liu yang i qui envoie une pièce on
peut pas vraiment se
on s'est construit mais on ne sait pas
mais en tout cas et young qui a décidé
de mettre à mal le meilleur défenseur du
circuit en faisant il ay de génie mais
pourquoi pas ça a l'air intéressant
il en fait il se dit qu'il a plein de
pièces à l'attaqué il a toutes ces
pièces encore très chic et qui sont là
peut venir le roi pour mon temps j'ai
deux peuples transfert de la tour voire
même f4 pour encore mieux en conception
g5 et jouer tout rage de fabien ligne
wesley qui est là avec toutes ces pièces
à l'état donc alors qu'ils trouvent kg 5
bon j'imagine qu'ils vaquent à me le
prendre la fin oui c'est normal toute
façon pourquoi torres cavaliers mais là
faut qu'il trouve un bon coup mais ça
pourrait être un man une master fils de
young et ça pourrait être une des partie
de l'année du nyong il a en finale deux
nations cup s'il réussit à à ce match
est comme ça son adversaire ça pourrait
être une énorme partie en face à l'arago
zine dont quelqu'un dans le cloud qui
nous dit qu'ils nous disaient énorme de
défense de oui peut-être mais carnaille
potable dans cette nations cup
détrompe toi caruana il a six et demi
sur huit donc les huit partis il a fait
sien il a une manie 5 et 3 nuls
j'aimerais bien ne pas être au top pas
aussi après ça et peut-être que les gens
attendaient un 8 sur 8 à une performance
à 3400 mais bon peut-on se contenter
d'une performance à 3000 à part alors je
pense que c'est un c'est le meilleur
joueur de la compétition et combattre
mais mon papa très en forme alors
maintenant c'est l'ami rinne a crush qui
va peut-être forcé son adversaire à
faire perpétuelle puisque c'est elle qui
avions passé de plus avancés on sait que
c'est un facteur en finale de dames
oui même si elle a un tour - ce qui
compte c'est la qualité des pions pas
vers la quantité a donc peut-être elle
va obliger dameuse d'un match 5-1
bêtement un truc comme ça
et donc ça serait nulle comme tu le
montrait tout à l'heure mais couleurs
inversées avec du damage cinq dames d1
le roi qui bouge je suis aller retour et
la dame qui l'attaqué chaque coup donc
écoute bien jouer pour irina crush alors
c'est nu le signe après faut compter
cinq échecs étonnant il caron qui n'a
pas qui n'est pas allé plus loin et ben
ben écoute toi tu que la finale a été
facilement au mieux mais ça donne
l'impression que peut-être ils pouvaient
s'ils poussent un peu dur alors on va on
va aller voir hugh parce qu'il vient de
faire tout rejet si soudée 5 et
l'ordinateur annonceurs incroyable qu'un
tremblement de terre pour les états unis
fabien et caro qui fait nul alors qu'il
pouvait peut-être pressé et c'est vrai
que là si hugh gagne le match est
quasiment finie il faut des stocks six
personnes ouais extraordinaire liu yang
yu yang il a qui est en train de faire
de faire son match très bien c'est une
grosse grosse fortune c'est c'est assez
extraordinaire côté chinois race qui est
en train de se passer et hikaru qui a
peut-être fait nul trop vite fabien eu
sûrement enfin là c'est je sais pas ce
qui était absolument pas en danger
est ce étonnant étonnant comme décision
mais lyon lille qu'on voit pas trois
caméras infra fallait encore dans mes
toiles et à traduire ses couches ou des
seins et qu'en fait il le met en prise
mais pas vraiment parce que le pion
devant la dame noire avec loane scipion
grand four par adam prend dames et 10 si
le flou cloisonne un peu plus le roi
noir qui pourra pas revenir se cacher
vers la case g8 et le deuxième problème
c'est qu'il se donne la possibilité de
monter son roi en g2 et faire tout
rachat alors vous me demandez pourquoi
il n'a pas fait damages quatre échecs
c'est adam qui règne sur la colonne en
face du roi simplement parce que les
noirs auraient plus je me coûte défense
tourage 6 donc voilà les sources mais
elle a donc tout à fait ce sera la tour
devant droit et elle serait pas en prise
avec un clouage donc il ya beaucoup de
cloche dans cette position de part et
d'autre et c'est un peu le thème qui
fait tenir la position pas
montrer qu'il aurait pu repartir vers le
sang éventuellement on joue et toura
justice suit son ouvrage 6 voilà parce
que plus on prend toujours pas possible
vu que vaille et au programme donc en
fait en jouant son coût douche ou des
cinq îles by claude le roy qui va
repartir
et il veut jouer roger de dompter son
roi avec les blancs est passée la tour
et donc ce ne sera pas la dame qui
viendrait donner le coup de grâce sur
cette colonne h ouverte mais la tour et
ça ça peut arriver dans la défendre pour
les noix et sûrement impossible si on en
croit la jauge qu'on voit sur le côté
qui monte est hyper aux côtés blanc
c'est un bijou fabien je crois vraiment
peu on peut vraiment appeler ça un bijou
en finale une partie comme sa partie
d'attac sacrifice de pièces à l'alpha 0
c'est ce extraordinaire de la part du
lion qui peut-être une préparation
d'ailleurs maintenant ce serait pas
étonnant et dans typiquement alfa 0
exactement c'est extraordinaire a
vraiment le joueur chinois qui fait
kiffer fait le boulot on le voit on voit
la caméra concentré alors que wesley
fait la tête des mauvais jours d'errance
voit plus vraiment sa tête un vrai dire
on voit que son fou qui ramène le choix
peut-être pour le sommeil ouais ça le
chat on allie peut encore faire quelque
chose dans cette partie va être tout à
fait je vais peut-être un peu recadré
aussi on va perdre les cheveux mais on
aura au maximum cet automne on voit le
maximum de so nice au saut qui est
vraiment dominé dans cette partie 1
complètement fait 4 alors faire nôtre
quand même faire et maintenant pour ya
plein de bons coups à prendre feu cannes
c'est un rêve c'est tfou pranger 6
j'ai passé non mais je pense comprendre
son idée de notre 4x heureuse et de le
faire faut projet st la focale jouer liu
yang qui te laisse même pas à montrer
l'idée kwaito louis fabien veut montrer
l'idée de défense sûrement pas
aujourd'hui bref cet été prises angers 6
qui arrivent et je crois que c'est
quasiment un an
et alors bertrand le menteur parce que
même si 40 a gagné des matches
alors maintenant ça irina crash de faire
parler des pions et ouais mais bon
non c'est beaucoup demander lui a fait
jouer une lande de des changes pour
faire annuler la bien rempli son rôle
et du coup le problème c'est que il est
trop tard maintenant pour rio linda
petite gastro logique est donc elle peut
essayer de tourner longtemps mais ça va
peut être sa patronne possible alors
faut pranger 5 jouer mais à voir juste
hors dé 6,1 plein plein plein comme
étant des six à l'air d'être le meilleur
de loin parce que attaque la tour deux
fois sur x l6 pour couvrir projet de
montrer comme ça sur le coup toutes les
idées marche
l'attak latéral le clouage la tour soit
colonna venir de partout
bon là je suis peut-être à air france
les six noms mais je trouve si on prend
et tour h
et c'est ma trompette un poids de 4 ans
extraordinaires insérant une thune party
d'exception fabien toi tout est bon pour
l'analyse à un jeu pensant parce que
franchement fabien des belles parties on
en voit de temps en temps et c'est là ça
a vraiment l'air d'être un travail
d'orfèvre chinois complètement
j'ai envie de dire où est ce les audois
c'est ce qui est en train de se faire
torturer il va parler couramment chinois
après la partie justement non mais le
problème des nains
ça a été ces pièces là bas croupe un
bougé de la ccc extraordinaire fabien je
pèse mes mots vraiment c'est une très
belle partie
maintenant le fantastique - wihongi
sûrement ramener la coupe à la maison
que des chinois
alors tout est bon pour que l 3 échecs
tu dernière tentative pour essayer de
ramener le roi sur une case pour bloquer
mais je pense même roy prend les rails
jouable j'étais en train de me refuser
cas 3g de vous prend d un mets tout
reprend des uns et la tour qui revient
vers h1 même sa jeunesse est pas
forcément le plus précis mais regardez
les noirs qui ont une tournée de plus et
qui ne peuvent pas défendre contre le
simple tour à charleroi qui est bloqué
la dame on peut pas interposés quoi que
ce soit le fou qui coule à tour et tout
un chacun arrive quoi qu'il se passe pas
bien c'est extraordinaire
la géométrie extraordinaire symphonie
des cases blanches
oui non vraiment vraiment une partie xxl
côté côté junghee qui peut vraiment être
fier de sa performance
franchement c'est beau c'est beau quand
une compétition se gagne sur une tête
partie fabien alors il tente le faire à
craon leskiw cette raison que tous les
coups possibles tout est gagnant mais
après franchement j'aime bien leur antre
ouais enfin j'adore à vendre ce que ça
te redonne la tour et ça déclenche une
pièce mais ça te dit oui bon bah c'est
normal qu'on fait et il le fait en plus
si l'esthétique jusqu'au bout liu yang
c'est beau fabien les échecs quand c'est
jouer comme ça c'est ce extraordinaire
mais d'autres partis belles belles
belles parts à part bravo est le chat
qui finalement n'aura pas fait la
différence mais personne n'y croit plus
fort 1 alors que le perpétuel a été
trouvé côté côté championne pr numéro un
mondial ou lifan et donc tout où le tout
le destin des américains est malade et
des chinois est maintenant dans les
mains de young et ses yun junghee fini
la partie
ce sera fini les l'équipe de chine sera
déclaré vainqueur de la compétition
et là je pense qu'à une cote de 10000
contraint je ne prendrai toujours pas
les états unis brottes notre un petit
euro symbolique dessus tout cas où on ne
sait jamais a aussi fait la droite et de
plusieurs déconnexions un truc
wesley qui abandonne ça y est c'est fini
fabien la chine qui s'impose dans cette
compétition la chine qui s'impose alors
que
fabiano caruana est en train de
s'imposer lui aussi avec les blancs
finalement la défense de fer de wailly
il n'aura pas tenu
mais mais ça ne changera rien fabien ben
écoute vraiment bravo bravo bravo
chinois hu en quelque sorte une grosse
grosse partie ce que battre west les
sauces c'est très dur il était à hauteur
de la tâche alors après les américains
pourront regretter que les carottes
étaient pas jouer plus et en fait avant
le match ils auraient signé des oeuvres
mais il a été honnête mans je pense que
c'est une erreur de la partie qu'à rouen
pendant le match qu'il a joint un peu
perso là-dessus maxilly bon ben moi je
colle top j'ai fait nul contre dingle
qui est très fort un an 3 mondial a mis
un chinois he may mais c'est dommage qui
je sais pas qui est peut être consignes
dans l'oreillette j'ai envie de dire
pour lire vos attentes et guerre ce soit
ce match et wesley falloir que tu la
joues
alors c'était les consignes étaient
interdites dans l'oreillette mais il
aurait pu par lui-même peut-être
regarder quoi que t'as pas le droit de
brancher l'ordinateur sur les parties
des autres c'était peut-être pas facile
mais a eu le site on sait rien
ouais mais il avait une position qui se
jouait il ya peut-être un peu mieux il
est plus fort c'est quand même le leader
de l'équipe fabien ouais mais tu me
fasses de dôme alors qu'il peut aller
continue parce que le capitaine il va
pouvoir savoir ça pour le match d'hier
pas un vrai temps réel
c'est justement le rôle principal d'un
capitaine d'équipé tu joues pas mais tu
vois ce qui se passe et tu peux dire un
joueur oui c'est bon tu que je pour
nulle ou non à bientôt un petit peu
dépité sur la carrière à 1
on a vu que j'avais fait un petit
mouvement au moment de la victoire de
young il a forcément vu sa fiche à son
écran sur son écran et là on le voit il
va finir à il va faire le taf jusqu'au
bout mais il sait que la finale ait
perdu ouais bon alors rien à se
reprocher pour le coup ça va lui faire
un beau si c'est mis sa tennis et milan
c'était déchirant sur neuf
cette émission la face à face à 13,9
vraiment petit phare gros fabiano
fabiano qui le seul point qu'il a ratée
de l'année finalement fabien sait les
candidats ou voilà les conditions de jeu
n'étaient pas forcément réunies pour
montrer le meilleur et on en a souvent
parlé avec toi mais un tour à des
candidats qui a peut-être été un petit
peu tronqué par par cette crise du corps
n'a plus comme qui peut c'est quand même
dommage de se dire qu'un joueur de la
qualité de caruana ne gagnera peut-être
pas les candidats annoncés demain enfin
mme parisot a répondu tout même en
ratant deux tournois il est quand même à
50% et les parcours seront des candidats
à mi parcours
donc on rappelle pourquoi doivent pas le
tour des candidats c'est un tournoi qui
réunit huit joueurs qui ont disqualifié
pendant arriver là et le vainqueur de ce
tournoi là va affronter le champion du
monde dans un match en un v1
six mois plus tard alors expliqué sommet
on ne sait pas un fabien d'ailleurs est
ce que le cycle radio x qui devra être
repoussée ce serait un autre mais mais
non pour le gouvello tournant des
candidats devaient avoir lieu
mi mars jusqu'à début avril en russie et
évidemment vous savez tous la crise du
coroner est arrivé et ils ont quand même
maintenu le temps à coûte que coûte
alors les joueurs ont beaucoup de peine
à y aller il ya même un joueur qui s'est
retiré du tournoi radjabov la petite va
se tendre avec l'équipe du reste du
monde
jugeant que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies pour assurer la sécurité alors
alors que la femme essayer de te couper
ça y est abandon de why et donc fabiano
qui finit à cet ennemi sur 9ème veepee
de la compétition mais finalement le
vrai défi de cette compétition c'est
peut-être une anguille à fabien qui dort
a perdu dans le détail n'ont apporté la
victoire à tout cas est d'abord l'équipe
de chine qui était favorite mais ils ont
tenu leur standing cessez jamais une
mince affaire
et puis et bella et la concurrence en
face et les belges équipe
donc franchement bravo à eux et donc
pour finir cette histoire du tour des
candidats juste pour dire que bah en
fait oui ils sont rendus à l'évidence
ils ont raté en plein milieu eddy louis
bourgeois quand on pourra alors c'est
pas dans deux mois dans six mois dans un
an
jamais voilà on la sait pas mais bon la
bonne nouvelle quand même pour ceux qui
découvrent les échecs et qui ne
connaissent pas le classement actuel de
son nom là on a un français maxime
vachier lagrave donc été le leader de
l'équipe européenne qui est co leader du
tournoi avec yann nepomniachi qui était
le leader de l'équipe russe et donc
caruana qui était le grand favori de
cette compétition avec dix mille irène
garde toutes ses chances dans un pour un
possible retour du tournoi - fabien qui
ne soit juste complètement annulé
suivant les développements futurs on
n'en sait rien sa tendance à mai mais
oui si on repense ça se passe sur leurs
toits la normale ou pas etc etc
et tu vois finalement dans ce match
assez serré titre qui a gagné la phase
de poules qui l'entretient davantage
l'avantagent du tournoi finalement reste
à la fin et comme je te disais enfin
comme on se disait tout à l'heure c'est
plutôt une bonne chose quelque part que
cette phase de poules qui a quand même
été longue
récompenses quelque part
avec deux choses plus que juste qualifié
deux équipes tout cas extraordinaire
victoire de la chine qui montrent que
c'est vraiment devenu un grand pays des
chats qui leur manque plus qu'un
champion du monde et ils seront vraiment
au sommet de la hiérarchie mondiale dans
toutes les formes d chacun que ce soit
en longs gants rapide en équipe
individuelle mais il leur manque encore
le titre qui est l'aliment eu chaque
féminin avec john john weave al-houni
fans
et puis même avant si où je vous chie
peut-être prononcer je peux comprendre
mais sous john peut-être aussi j'suis
john bonvin et ben ouais mais donc là
leur meilleur espoir ça threading
lierait les camions aux 3 mondial après
devant lui pour le coup le temps des
candidats un peu loin sera pas pour
cette année mais qui savent lire et
encore jeune mais l'iton qu'en faire de
belles choses
re montre quand même la partie décisive
rapidement qu on analysera probablement
un fabien parce qu'elle est vraiment
vraiment sympathique mais on va vous la
faire en relais pour la retrouver sur la
chaîne youtube greenstream donc après le
après le tournoi peut-être demain ou
après demain
puis suivant à quelle vitesse on fait ça
avec fable mais une partie
exceptionnelle de du gant du clan
nouvelle parce qu'en fait bon ça c'est
l'ouverture ça soit ça devrait
normalement une position symétrique on a
tous à peu près la même pièce 2 to
chacun qui avaient chacun et en surtout
donné l'accent sur la partie 10 cas où
donc on a vu qu'on s'est passé mais tout
d'un coup les marcheurs truc
complètement fermée
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait à 6 on voit qu'il
a dû retourner chez lui pour repartir il
est perdu beaucoup de temps pour le
gagner un pion pendant que les blancs se
met en place et tout d'un coup ça a été
la punition des pièces dont je ressens
hamas ihab el roque et c'est pas rien
puisque les sauces comme sacré défenseur
mais là c'est pas mal à son idée de
lashkar donne la pièce ouvre la colonne
etc et ce coup de grâce à icloud est
exceptionnel exceptionnel grande partie
grandes marques des meilleurs portiers
de la verte où quatre grandes parties
fabien je vais te poser la question que
j'ai posée aux
autres commentateurs mais que tu avais
gardé pour la fin comme satan a pu voir
toute la compétition
est ce que tu aimerais retrouver cette
compétition fabien sur le calendrier
en sachant que je vais te mettre un peu
le contexte que j'ai mis pour les autres
on a les olympiades qui sont
l'équivalent des jeux olympiques des
échecs ou d'une coupe du monde des
nations des échecs on a le championnat
d'europe par équipe qui est championne
d'europe et il ya des championnats par
équipes dans les autres régions du globe
bien évidemment mais on a aussi
finalement aux échecs cette compétition
qui à mon avis dans le calendrier est un
petit peu superflu le championnat du
monde par équipe qui réunit dix équipes
mais qui finalement fait un petit peu
double emploi avec
avec les olympiades donc est-ce que tu
souhaiterais pas que dans le futur cette
compétition cette coupe des nations ne
remplace finalement le championnat du
monde par équipe qui parle un peu
superflu
bon pourquoi pas après peut-être aussi
tout faire coexister tepa but de la
faire chaque année ce peut être une fois
tous les deux ans qui a inhalé les
olympiades de donner ce cette coupe des
nations
après ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'était un coup d'essai ce t'as pas que
cet effet je pense que le format peut
être améliorée doit être améliorée
d'ailleurs sur internet mais c'était pas
si mal mais la qualité de jeu était au
rendez vous ça sert à noter les genres
pas pressée de questions par dessus la
jambe
une belle partie bas notamment celles
ladakh été fantastique et je pense ça
peut être intéressant de faire de
continuer de voir les points forts
points faibles et d'améliorer sa petit à
petit donc c'est une compétition que tu
souhaites ray revoir au fil des années
que ce soit sur endurant réel sur
l'échiquier ou sur internet avec une
cadence rapide
je trouve que c'est quand même quelque
chose d'un petit peu nouveaux et
novateurs parlera par rapport aux autres
compétitions qui se répète un petit peu
fabien ouais mais même voiture le gard
nation internet puisque c'est né comme
ça un peu la gare et sur internet
pourquoi pas en fait il ça permet de
tout faire sur une semaine santé des
gens qui doivent voyager de partout etc
c'est peut-être pas mince r1 commencé un
peu se joue en ligne sérieux par type
touche ça peut être intéressant je pense
donc c'est une compétition qui t'a plu
et et aimerait se cinq coups d'essai qui
t'a plu et c'est une compétition que tu
aimerais pouvoir revoir dans calendrier
touati de personnel dans l'est dans les
années à venir
voilà alors après comme je dis un peu
quand même de débattre sur certains
petits points de détail a changé laurent
coûteux plus attractif faire violer
partie les unes après les autres
pas tous les matchs en même temps
changer le format la durée des parties
la pause entre les rondes à il ya plein
de trucs à discuter ça on met d'accord
je pense mais mais l'idée en soi n'est
pas mal sur le principe on va dire
tuvalu
voila voila voila tu valides la
compétition bah écoute on est du même
avis du coup fabien moi aussi c'est une
compétition que j'ai vraiment aimé
suivre
j'ai été agréablement surpris par le
niveau de jeu
par l'implication des joueurs tout au
long de la compétition on a senti
vraiment une grande déception notamment
chez les européens après après
l'élimination la place par en fait été
assez mécontents on a senti que les
joueurs que ce soit dans le niveau de
jeu ou dans les interviews qu'ils
étaient vraiment impliqué cette finale
elle a confirmé ça puisqu'on a vu que
les joueurs avaient vraiment tout donné
pour pour l'emporter
donc pour moi c'est aussi la barre
valide ainsi validé c'est un oui c'est
un oui bah c'est cool après ben faites
nous des retours si vous avez aimé vous
de votre côté mais je pense que ça vaut
le coup c'était bien c'était plutôt bien
et au classement le classement final
pour leur montrer donc avant cette
finale pour montrer un petit est fini ou
pour conclure là dessus on voit que la
chine donc là enfin leur porte et là en
finale elle est fille devant les états
unis l'europe quand même qui s'est bien
comportée finissant deuxièmes ex-aequo
troisième en départage déception pour la
russie qui finit 4e l'inde qui
finalement c'est à jouer sur des détails
il aurait pu être beaucoup plus
dangereux et l'équipe du reste du monde
qui était une équipe et un peu
exhibition qui finit dernière mais qui a
montré de belles choses aussi au mieux
les matches étaient plutôt serré en
général en plus pas besoin d'eux
et puis là et qui du reste du monde qui
te coûte la qualification visiteurs
j'avais mais non ils ont joué un rôle
d'arbitré avec fear ouja qui était un
peu l'attraction aussi de la compétition
donc assez sympa si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit follow
sur la chaîne chasse comme france twitch
ça fait plaisir si vous souhaitez jouer
aux échecs il faut toujours jouer sur la
plateforme chez ce point comme et pour
progresser vous avez tout un tas de deux
solutions avec chaises comme 2
de package de vidéos d'entraînement etc
que vous retrouverez sur sur le site
avec notamment 125 ne sont pas bien pour
bien c'est comme ça en français puis
tout un tas d'autres leçons de
d'ordinateurs de finale de match enfin
voila c'est une offre très complète
on vous remercie encore et on vous dis à
très bientôt pour de futures
compétitions et notamment la semaine
prochaine le championnat de france de
rapides et de blitz les deux minutes
plus tôt klose